[Musique]
hier c'était le jubilé de la reine
d'angleterre qui fêtait ses 70 ans de
règne ont l'occasion les chaînes de tv
ont envoyé leurs journalistes un peu
partout vous êtes dans un black câble
magnifique calèche vous déplacer sur la
tamise et on n'a pas trop compris le
projet de denis brogniart on aura un
crieur public au nom un joueur de
cornemuse je suis entouré de musiciens
qui viennent damien des trésors dans
l'arène a fait son apparition devant la
foule en délire pour fêter ce jubilé on
a vu de belles parades entendu de goût
de canon est aperçu les avions qui
faisait visiblement un peu trop bruit et
lightning ce sont des f 35 b
bref ce soir on revient sur les deux
images qui ont marqué le règne de la
reine d'angleterre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
je vous rappelle me rappelle que pour
cyril c'est à cause des anglais le stade
de france dont calmez-vous quand même ou
alors j'ai très vite avec vous moi
j'adore le voilà j'adore l'angleterre il
est la reine mais alors que j'ai vu le
défilé franchement c'était c'était
pourri c'était milite fribourg et
northpet s'est éclaté au sol aux bahamas
mais on va y aller il y avait trop
pauvre soldat avec laure leur tuque en
tout flamme
depuis je sais que vous avez dit que
c'était paul bourre son jeu ça très en
colère s'en sort sa sellette ce poids
lourds sont deux femelles wee bb des
vrais morceaux de booba
drapeau c'est mon petit cadeau pour vous
ça tout est histoire de l'héberger ils
sont
bien connus
comme ça mais ça me touche pas vous
sortez les voir soudainement bakou
daniel calme toi et tu parles du drapeau
alors on va revenir on va revenir en
images sur cette carrière
cette ce règne incroyable 1942 c'est la
première allocution de la reine
d'angleterre des deux n'a que 14 ans et
les adresses
14h à gauche
c'est un corbillard et wis on est en
1942 après que sa première allocution à
la radio et à s'adresse au peuple
londonien et anglais regardez écoutez
ses deux mines d'or qu'elle fait sa
première grande allocution pour remonter
le moral des enfants qui ont été évacués
minerve emery mal est fait et puis elle
un goût amer comme le capot elle
respecte pris un pli
elle même tout comme le même banc il
faut vous faire
que les fidèles mais voilà
qu'elle
est d'accord
c'est ma tête alors du monde ce que l'on
peut dire c'est que sam c'est sa mère la
célébrissime queen mum qui va république
on connaît
ils firent qui l'a aidé à caler sa
respiration a posé sa voile n'est pas
encore la grande professionnelle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui et elles sont au château
de windsor parce qu'à un moment donné on
pense qu'on va les envoyer au canada et
la reine dans queen mum sa maman dit il
en est hors de question les princesses
ne partiront pas sans moi moi je ne
partirai pas sans le roi et le roi ne
partira pas sans ces sujets c'est bon
quelques jours plus tard le palais de
buckingham et bombardier et quelques
minutes après le bombardement la famille
royale sort le roi et la reine maquiller
papon et il traverse les rues ils disent
désormais nous pouvons regarder les
londoniens droit dans les yeux tout cela
pour vous dire que c'est quasiment le
seul roi historiquement qui est resté
j'ai rester en place durant les cinq ans
de conflit c'est beau saison de chasse
est une sorte et elles ne le savent pas
mais en réalité à quelques mètres d'elle
dans la tour du château il ya également
les joyaux de la couronne ont été
emballés main s'élancer vers le
cambriolage et lahoud
bien 1947 son mariage à elle va se
marier avec philippe oui ok des princes
consiste ce matin on a tout juste 20 ans
alors on va là les images mais
apparemment c'était pas un choix le
meilleur choix alors d'accord c'est or
la d imagerie pape elle est belle ce 20
novembre 1947 dans le royaume uni
d'après guerre elisabeth future reine
d'angleterre
épouse celui qu'elle a choisi le prince
philip de grèce et du danemark
la foule rassemblée en masse exulte la
jeune elizabeth à imposer à sa famille
celui pour lequel elle a eu le coup de
foudre huit ans plus tôt philippe mans
de baten n'a pas vraiment le pedigree
parfait prince certes mais désargenté et
sa soeur ont déposé des nazis sûr de son
choix la princesse les pousse devant st
croix 5 rennes et 200 millions de
spectateurs qui suivent la
retransmission télévisée à partir de ce
jour de 1947 le couple princier incarne
la modernité
l'avenir de la monarchie
alors elle a rencontré les princes et
les à l'âge de 13 ans
et apparemment des frangins de luke de
philippe là il était border quand même
ça rompt tous épousé des officiers nazis
ne seront pas présentes d'ailleurs lors
de la série imaginée par 1947 et la
toute première fois que londres nous
avec le faste ont à peine sorti de la
guerre on sait que la robe a été acheté
avec des tickets de rationnement puisque
londres est encore rationnés et ces
drogues elle paraît comme ça agréable et
scintillante et merveilleuse c'est tout
sauf le contraire à ce que les dames
d'honneur diront ils ont la l2 ont le
même tissu que que la robe lorsqu'elles
ont retiré cette fameuse robe elle était
couverte de plaques rouges tellement le
tissu n'était pas agréable c'était mal
rideau qui était à peu voilà c'est cela
et c'est donc voilà c'est une robe kaki
qui paraît majestueuse mais qui ne l'est
pas c'est uniquement à balai ou de
madras là c'est la guerre il de la pac
heurter à une petite anecdote le diadème
que l'on voit qu'elle porte à 46 le
zirconium savons rien flamand et bien 47
barrette en diamant aux riches voilà et
on les a on l'a on le sort du sac ou le
matin même et il se brise au moment où
on l'a coiffé on pose le diadème sources
assurent ses cheveux sur la chevelure on
apprendra plus tard convient l'insee pas
prise et du tout il ya un petit
mécanisme au centre qui permet de le
métamorphoser en collier
nous en étions à son mariage avec le
prince philip alors dont on dit qu'il
était un peu volage
on peut lire l'arrêt des cocus
la reine avocat
club du jeudi alors il faut les jeudis
ballista pesait on est fléché des
officiers dans les 103 la crêpe et
officiers de la marine absolument oui et
alors on sait en effet maintenant on
peut le dire s'est révélée dans ce
crunch alors que en effet il a été
entendu
mais elle elle l'aimé d'un amour à
considérer que c'est vrai et elle dit
que voilà n'a pas vraiment revendiquer
sa fidélité physique est la plus tôt
revendiqué une fidélité noeuds remier de
ses chevaliers l'a jamais prendre mais
elle va à bout d'angers alors élue elle
deviendra la reja mais non là où vous
excuser le prince philip mon coeur est à
marennes bon sexe et à tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
alors les choses sérieuses vont
commencer en 1953 avec le couronnement
mais que queen même envoyé va pas à
l'école
je suis pas de godard canton cantat
passent leurs magots c'est quoi le
bridge john
adams autrement dit ce sera pour elle à
la pompe pour l'avion ne connais rien
georget six marques s'y fait chier 52 à
la tête de la seconde où il décède elle
devient reine et au kenya elle revient
en urgence oui il faut non et c'est là
ce retour du kenya était elle dit au
prince consort à son mari et lui dit de
pas dans l'ariège avec désormais alors
ça on le voit très bien dans de
probables cette série qui alors là tu es
dont une est magnifique cité des images
incroyables et donc elle a demandé à son
mari maintenant tu as fait tu as fait le
bolat a fait tant qu'ils restent
derrière pas rentrer dans le match va
rentrer dans l'ordre m'étonne pas mais
la très très difficile ils sont très
jeunes à la 24 ans lorsqu'elle devient
reine en effet on le sait et il faut un
nom de préparatifs pour arriver à cette
cérémonie incroyable du couronnement eh
bien regardez le 2 juin à saint quentin
on regarde ça
au moment où sous les yeux de ses deux
enfants la reine elizabeth dans toute sa
majesté sort du palais de buckingham 10
millions de citoyens britanniques et un
demi million de visiteurs d'étrangers
s'apprête à vue vers un triomphe comme
on en vit jamais
elle est très belle la reine
s'était pas de couronnement c'est la
cérémonie vraiment de l'histoire
regarder deux secondes la robe elle est
faite par norman arnel sachez quand même
que le montana n'étaient pas des
monstres le jupon qu'elle portait en
crin de cheval là vraiment là il faut
qu'ils arrêtent et vous animez les jours
ses jours soient possibilité de nos
cibles le crin de cheval par le coup
c'est ouais d'accord elle est tellement
lourde pourquoi parce qu'elle est
rebrodé aussi d'or de tous les emblèmes
du royaume depuis deux jours elle ne
mange que des oeufs durs et du sel
pourquoi il est impossible de retirer
cette cct drôle il ya elle ne peut pas
avoir besoin de telle ou telle chose
c'est impossible a déjà vu la reine oui
absolument à paris les sables oui à la
balle à terre mais tu l'as vu cette
élite il a rencontré la reine moi si
j'ai vu la tête qu'elle
ouvre 1/4 de voyages de presse jeunes et
non je n'ai jamais vraiment parlé
directement avril que l'on peut
peut-être dire c'est que dès que
quelqu'un allait présenter à la reine
les plus grands savants l'ont été par
exemple eh bien ils paient ils en
perdent leur latin et pousse nous
époustoufler tellement impressionné pour
le coup qui raconte très souvent
n'importe quoi on doit faire le sac
anton van haaren on doit
l'aider
d'accord alors les couronnements on dit
tout peut peut-être durant la cérémonie
elle va porter cette fameuse couronne
qui passent plus de 3 kg et 32 kg c'est
en or et avec des diamants voulait plus
prendre s'apprête à son dossier sera
couronne la fameuse couronne de
saint-édouard c'est pas comme ça que
vous ferez la cci-ci
maladie muscler ses certificats comment
mais ce n'est pas que moi je lui ai fait
du sport pour porter un week end à blanc
et
il devait être double là le temps de
charge
1981 le mariage j'ai vu à la télévision
c'est quand quand bayane à épouser un
charles oui bon ça moi je n'avais
évidemment pas nourrir la presse pendant
des années demander jusqu'où est on
vantera j'ai de la compassion de diana
on va revoir ces images c'est le 29
juillet 1981 et la charles et lady di se
marier mais moi j'étais devant ma télé
même moins
le scénario semblait parfait un conte de
fées à buckingham avec le prince
charmant ce 29 juillet 1981 jamais
autant de personnes en avaient regardé
une seule
750 millions de téléspectateurs record à
l'époque aimanté par cette cendrillon
sortie du carrosse
[Applaudissements]
lady diana spencer mais pour l'héritier
du trône aussi c'est un grand jour
il était temps que le coureur de jupons
retrouve le droit chemin aux yeux de sa
mère la reine elizabeth ii
[Applaudissements]
est fausse quelqu'un il a
semblé pas du tout sens être comme cela
on va dire que lorsqu'elle rentre on l'a
vu tout à l'heure dans le carrosse de
verre elle quitte donc la résidence de
clarence house pour se rendre à l'abbaye
dans le carrosse de faire et là on
s'aperçoit que la traîne est tellement
volumineuse elle fait plus de 7 m on ne
sait plus où la m et alors on lan roues
ils vraiment les officiers on roule la
traîne et beau-frère
[Applaudissements]
elisabeth et davy d'emmanuel découvrez
la robe elle est toutefois ça s'est
vu à la base la presse anglaise
baptisera ce tissu en disant 'il est
bouillonnant et ben il va être à l'image
du couple qui va évidemment puisque en
97 c'est la mort de diana
s'étaient 31 août 97 sous le pont de
l'alma évidemment on a tous vu ces
images ont évidemment les revoir
regarder
à cet instant londres retient son
souffle et comme son peuple la reine
accompagnée d'une partie de la famille
royale est descendue dans la rue pour
rendre hommage à la princesse de galles
une princesse que la reine avait
dépouillé de son titre d'altesse royale
et pousser ou divorce mais aujourd'hui
la reine s'est incliné devant elle pour
la première fois dans l'histoire la
reine a fait mettre le drapeau
britannique en berne sur son château de
buckingham une démarche non prévues au
protocole mais qui pourrait bien marquer
le début d'une réconciliation entre les
britanniques et leur monarchie
début de la conciliation pas vraiment
je trouve
qu'elle est morte oui d'accord on
rappelle le 31 août il était précisément
minuit à
percute le 13e piliers en béton sous le
pont de l'alma elle mord en effet elle
est au summum de sa popularité mais deux
en un an elle n'est plus a été serein et
non des divorcés la bourse elle est en
réalité lorsqu'elle apprend sa mort
elizabeth ii réagi en reine en
souveraine a dit puisqu'elle n'est plus
altesse royal elle n'aura donc pas des
funérailles d'état et on voit que tu te
la polémique ne cesse de mes vieilles il
ya eu depuis dans la vie elle revient la
décision et il y aura donc en effet
définir à ce sommet qui les deux vous
avez quel est le coût pour une princesse
je sais pas si vous avez raison d'eux
[Applaudissements]
après peut-être après
2011 2011 le mariage de william et 2 et
2 et 2 commence à peine
alors il est là que je viens qu'elle
puisse elle même parce que moi je n'ai
vu qu'une seule famille pas j'ai bu
pippa alors il part turquie alors c'est
une bombe a pu passer son cul non mais
j'ai beau me
passa il a encore des cheveux là encore
des cheveux il n'a pas la testostérone
qui remontait à la tête et ça va venir
après on gagne des matches
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas envie parce
que j'avais l'image
c'est pas de faire l'ombre d'autres
images montrent
le prince allait pour diriger le louche
si nous faisons est chez nous hier bas à
gauche trafic local à l écoute et alors
l'audience a mis un milliard de
téléspectateurs
l'un d'eux ont frôlé deux milliards a
foulé deux milliards si les des maisons
des demandeurs par million certain que
ça va tenir
tête tellement il ya de nombre de
téléspectateurs en effet on rappelle aux
houles justement là justement sur la
robe et on rappelle cocorico c'est de la
dentelle de caudry pour écoeurer fiolet
la française conneries que tu appelles
andaloussiate ni entre allemagne des
salles assez l'une à 17 ans c'est en
peau de quoi de quel animal on est à
personne
je cite je suis rassuré alors évidemment
laissé sur la monarchie des embrouilles
il ya le mexique le mexique les makes it
de quoi le mexique contraction de megan
était pas là si tu le mettras la mégane
à des galas prend la route
pas mal mais yen à quel point la route
avec jean marais et alcar vivent à los
angeles riel keeps la royauté et ci
renonce à tous leurs privilèges mais
vous savez que vous parlez de l'accueil
temps vous parlez d'une hotte de mais
quel jeu par dominion visite
j'en ai toujours bien en janvier 2000
voilà du vigeant classe a limogé jeudi l
orgue la stoppe cette triste 1 c'est
vraiment un très bon barbecue décide de
partir parce dans le contexte dans
lequel ça va être fait puisqu'ils
annoncent sur leur site internet et ils
préviennent seulement la bbc qu'ils vont
le faire et c'est le directeur de la bbc
qui appelle le secrétaire d'elizabeth ii
pour lui dire dans une demi heure on
balance la faute et mégane ont décidé
désormais qu'ils ne feront plus partie
de la famille royale c'est comme ça que
la reine la prends comme une gifle
alors on allait on a l'image de soirée
terrible quand même je peux pas famille
royale traverse une crise harry et son
épouse mégane ont annoncé leur désir
d'indépendance
la reine a tranché et imposer ses
conditions harry et mégane devront
renoncer à leur titre d'altesse royale
et aux revenus qui monte avec une
décision acceptée par le couple
la reine a tout de même tenu à rassurer
dans un communiqué harry mégane et
archie seront toujours des membres très
aimé de ma famille voilà donc
il y aura derrière alors dans les
moments importants on va inventer un peu
il ya la locution pour le coc vide la
reine d'angleterre va peut s'adresser à
son peuple oui ce qui est arrivé que
très peu de fois absolument c'était
arrivé quatre fois et pourquoi le
fait-elle pas ce que boris johnson jala
parle coronavirus il ne peut le faire il
est alité il est très très mal le prince
william lui aussi est alité très mal on
se souvient que l'angleterre a eu
énormément de victimes et elles décident
elles de prendre la parole elle est en
verre vert couleur de l'espoir très bien
en 21 c'est la mort de philippe aumont
très compliqué pour la reine absolument
donc le prince consort passe la main
gauche
seulement parts assister aux funérailles
dans la chapelle saint georges on ne l'a
jamais vue aussi seul on n'a jamais vu
un si triste et terrible
la lame lapize influentes du monde hélas
elle paraît vrai
et là je suis la reine dont elle est
chaque année ne met pas des magazines
comme étant la femme la plus influente
est donc envisagé pour minsk
et mozart si guy lamarque a formé un
lieu à forte a informé très bien et puis
bien sûr on arrive en 2022 le jubilé
platine dont on a évidemment beaucoup
beaucoup de fils et on arrive où partent
et demain pour le pour l'angleterre pour
le concert
alors la halle se repose et demain tu
étais ressort aujourd'hui c'était queen
out on espère bien que demain ce nouveau
queen we l'utérus est là mais beaucoup
d'admiration pour elle non mais non
j'aimerais c'est incroyable beaucoup
d'admiration je la trouve digne dans
toute circonstance
il ya eu juste la petite erreur grosse
télé dinelli magnifique quand elle voit
ses enfants qui se bat khaldi il reste
aux nounous chers membres très estimé de
l'élégance en tout cas longue vie à la
reine 85 vie à la reine et en espérant
que sont les objets
[Applaudissements]